[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend schön dass
Sie dabei sind wie auch Norbert Lehmann
mit erfolgreichen Wolfsburgerinnen ein
sogenannter von mir schauen wir auf die
Themen von heute
Kampf ums Klima beim Petersberger
klimadialog fordert Außenministerin
baerbock den weltweiten Ausbau von
erneuerbaren Energien
Streik Thema klimak die sogenannte
letzte Generation will ihre Proteste
fortsetzen heute gab es ein Treffen mit
Verkehrsminister
und der Traum vom Titel die
Fußballerinnen des VfL Wolfsburg stehen
nach dem Sieg gegen Arsenal im Finale
der Champions League
[Musik]
wir haben zu lange weggeschaut sagte
UN-Generalsekretär gut heute zum Auftakt
des Petersberger klimadialogs in Berlin
dort beraten Vertreter aus mehr als 40
Ländern über Schritte um die Klimaziele
zu erreichen bislang ging es kaum voran
alle Länder zusammen verursachen seit
Jahrzehnten stetig mehr CO2 nur in einem
Jahr ging der globale Ausstoß zurück
2020 wegen der corona-pandemie seitdem
stieg er auf neue Rekordwerte zuletzt
auf
36,8 Milliarden Tonnen in Deutschland
gibt es zwar seit Jahren einen leichten
Rückgang die enormen Emissionen der
Hauptverursacher China USA und Indien
fallen aber weit schwerer ins Gewicht
Winnie Hirscher
der Mann neben Annalena baerbock ist
Sultan ahmetischer Bär er kommt aus den
Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten und
sitzt hier als Gastgeber der nächsten
Weltklimakonferenz in Dubai dort würde
die grüne Außenministerin gerne ein
festes Datum für einen weltweiten
Ausstieg aus fossilen Energien
verabschieden darauf legt sich der
Sultan hier nicht fest
wir wissen dass die Energieträger die
heute genutzt werden auch Teil des
Energiemixes bleiben werdende näherer
Zukunft wir arbeiten mit der Welt daran
dass Energiesystem kohlenstoffarm zu
gestalten
die Emirate sind einer der größten
Ölproduzenten der Welt dass sie als
Vermittler zwischen fast 200 Staaten
auftreten können bezweifeln
Umweltschützer auch weil der Sultan
selbst einen Ölkonzern leitet es ist für
uns kaum auszuhalten dass ein Ölkonzern
Vorstand äh den Kompromiss finden muss
weltweit in der Klimakrise der sich an
der Wissenschaft orientieren muss und
die Wissenschaft ganz klar sagt müssen
raus aus der Verbrennung von Kohle Öl
und Gas die Außenministerin setzt ein
weiteres globales Ziel für erneuerbare
Energie
wenn wir die massiv ausbauen
insbesondere auch in Afrika dann können
wir gemeinsam dafür sorgen dass wir doch
noch auf den 1,5 Grad Fahrt kommen
ärmere Länder rufen dieser Runde zu
Erfolge bitte keine weiteren versprechen
die Weltklimakonferenz ist im Dezember
in Deutschland würde schon ein
Tempolimit auf Autobahnen helfen und
eine Neuauflage des 9-euro-tickets das
sagen die klimaaktivisten der
sogenannten letzten Generation seit zwei
Wochen verstärken sie ihre
Verkehrsblockaden in der Hauptstadt
heute sprachen sie mit Verkehrsminister
Wissing der vertritt Zitat 0 Toleranz
für Straftäter hält aber Gespräche in
einer Demokratie für wichtig Henriette
de Maiziere
das ist Berlin in diesen Tagen
Aktivistinnen und Aktivisten der
sogenannten letzten Generationen kleben
sich auf die Straßen der Hauptstadt
blockieren den Verkehr im Kampf für mehr
Klimaschutz laut einer zdf-umfrage unter
25 bis 34-Jährigen finden die Aktionen
der letzten Generation nur knapp 20% der
Befragten angemessen mehr als
Dreiviertel sehen die Aktionen negativ
heute ein Treffen der letzten Generation
mit Verkehrsminister Wissing zwei
Stunden haben sie geredet viel länger
als geplant
die Dringlichkeit der Klimakrise ganz
Herz legen wir haben darüber gesprochen
dass es die größte Bedrohung ist für
viele Menschen von uns die ja die wir
gerade haben wir haben über die
Maßnahmen Tempolimit und mein Euro
Ticket sprechen können zuletzt lief es
nicht gut zwischen dem Verkehrsminister
und der letzten Generation Farbattacke
auf das Ministerium im März der Vorwurf
der Minister Tour nicht genug für den
Klimaschutz erreiche die sektorenziele
nicht per Twitter hatte die letzte
Generation Wissing aufgefordert wir
möchten reden ein viertes Mal bitte
melden Sie sich bei uns es geht um die
Zukunft der Minister antwortete über
Klimaschutz reden und Ringen ja über
Blockaden anderen den eigenen Willen
aufzwingen nein darüber werde ich mit
der letzten Generation sprechen bereits
gestern kritisierte er die CO2
einsparforderungen also 9 euro-ticket
und Tempolimit das sind ja nur kleine
CO2 Einsparungen und wenn man sich
anschaut was wir auf den Weg bringen in
den letzten Monaten und jetzt auch mit
dem deutschland- sind das große
CO2-Einsparungen Mitte Mai will der
Verkehrsminister sein Klima
Sofortprogramm vorstellen danach ist
auch ein weiteres Gespräch mit der
letzten Generation geplant die Proteste
sollen bis dahin weitergehen
ein Aktivist der sogenannten letzten
Generation diskutiert bei heute live
gleich mit einem jungen Millionär der
keinen Anlass sieht sich einzuschränken
ab 19.30 auf unseren Social Media
Kanälen und über die ZDF heute App
die deutsche Wirtschaft beklagt seit
langem die hohen Energiepreise
hierzulande das sei ein
Wettbewerbsnachteil Wirtschaftsminister
Habeck will gegensteuern und den
Strompreis für die Industrie mit
staatlicher Hilfe noch weiter
vergünstigen doch aus der Ampel kommt
Gegenwind Finanzminister Lindner sagt
extrem teure Subventionen seien der
falsche Weg ähnlich äußert sich Kanzler
Scholz Deutschland könne es sich nicht
leisten den Strompreis für normale
wirtschaftliche Tätigkeiten zu
subventionieren fragen wir energy in
Berlin ist das Ganze damit vom Tisch
also ich würde die Idee noch nicht
gänzlich abschreiben denn es lohnt sich
da auch noch mal auf den genauen
Wortlaut zu gucken Christian Lindner
schreibt in seinen eigenen Worten ihr
seht das ganze sehr kritisch und Olaf
Scholz ist vor allem skeptisch bei einer
dauerhaften Subventionierung alle beide
betonen aber auch das worin sie sich mit
Harbeck einig sind nämlich das
energieintensive Unternehmen in dem
Übergang zu erneuerbaren Energien Hilfe
brauchen damit sie international
wettbewerbsfähig sein das will die
Bundesregierung wohl sicherstellen und
da ist jetzt eben die Frage was ist da
das beste Mittel bei habex Vorschlag dem
industriestrompreis stellt sich die
Frage woher kommt das Geld wie viel soll
es sein wer soll davon wie lange
profitieren und bei Lindners
Gegenvorschlag den er in einem Artikel
im Handelsblatt vorgestellt hat geht es
um Unternehmensbesteuerung und
Innovationsanreize da wird man dann am
Ende sicherlich fragen müssen wenn das
über den Haushalt geht wo wird dann
gespart denn das Geld muss ja auch
irgendwo herkommen also das ist eine
Diskussion die die Ampel ausfechten muss
es ist aber noch nichts ganz vom Tisch
also auch nicht der industriestrompreis
danke schön für diese Einschätzung der
Energy war das aus Berlin
folgerichtig und respektabel so
bezeichnen Spitzenvertreter der Grünen
den Parteiaustritt von Boris Palmer
gestern Abend kündigte der Tübinger
Oberbürgermeister überraschend an dass
er die Partei verlassen wird außerdem
will er eine Auszeit von einem Monat
nehmen und sich professionelle Hilfe
suchen vorausgegangen war ein Auftritt
Palmers am Freitag der große Impfung
auslöste Petra otto hat mehr ja
sie ist raus das ist nichts anderes
sterben ein Bruder Vergleich von Boris
Palmer und dann spricht er in der
Frankfurter Uni auch noch mehrfach das
für schwarze Menschen diskriminierende
aus ja ich benutze das Wort
durch auch hier in diesem Raum er
schießt einfach immer wieder übers Ziel
hinaus merkt er selbst
wenn ich mich zu Unrecht angegriffen
fühle und spontan reagiere wäre ich mich
in einer Weise die alles nur schlimmer
macht jetzt zieht Palma die Reißleine
persönliche Auszeit und Austritt aus der
Partei wir sehen an dem Fall was
passiert wenn Provokationen
gesellschaftliche Debatten bestimmen
dann läuft die Diskussion aus dem Ruder
man kommt nicht zu gesellschaftlich
tragfähigen Lösung für strittige Fragen
sondern es geht auf einmal um
Personalfragen und auch um die Frage was
ist noch angemessen was darf man sagen
was nicht der Vergleich mit dem
Judenstern ein No-Go meint auch der
baden-württembergische Ministerpräsident
Kretschmann der Boris Palmer schätzt
nach wie vor
das habe ich ihm deutlich gesagt
dass mein Zeug eine Äußerung unter gar
keinen Umständen machen kann
und in die Situation die er sich damit
selber gebracht hat in so einer
Situation muss man daran selber
rausfinden
seit gut einem Jahr vielleicht kommt er
mit dem Austritt jetzt im rauschmes
zuvor
gab ja Gründe warum wir viele
Diskussionen alle miteinander hatten
warum es ein Schiedsgerichtsverfahren
gab warum seine Mitgliedschaft gerade
ausgesetzt war in Tübingen da haben Sie
Boris Palmer schon drei Mal zum Obi
gewählt und viele wollen auch dass er
das bleibt er hat vielleicht viele
Wähler enttäuscht auch durch seine
Äußerung aber ich denke er sollte schon
im Amt bleiben ich hoffe dass er sich
jetzt Zeit für sich selbst und hilft ihm
weil er hat sich im Rathaus hat Boris
Palmer sich krank gemeldet keine
Veranstaltungen keine Talkshows es
dürfte nun also ruhiger werden um ihn
zumindest vorübergehend
im Sudan versuchen sich nach rund zwei
Wochen blutiger Unruhen immer mehr
Menschen in Sicherheit zu bringen
330.000 sind bereits innerhalb der
eigenen Grenzen geflüchtet weitere
hunderttausend haben das Land verlassen
viele Richtung Ägypten und Chat im Land
stehen sich zwei unerbittliche Gegner
gegenüber die Armee unter dem Kommando
von Machthaber alborhan und die Milizen
seines Stellvertreters
sie kommen fast ohne Vorräte sagen die
Helfer viele sind traumatisiert
Flüchtlinge aus dem Westen Sudans
erreichen den Schatz die Folgen des
Krieges im Sudan sind nach nur zwei
Wochen bereits in den Nachbarländern zu
spüren bei Nachbarn die selbst mit
Instabilität und Hunger kämpfen
so sieht es auf der sudanesischen Seite
der Grenze aus Schulen Märkte
Amtsgebäude wurden in Brand gesetzt hier
in der fuhr West Sudan hat der Krieg
zweier machthungriger Generäle auch noch
den stammeskrieg in dieser Region wieder
angefacht
die Armee ist hier geflohen
Paramilitärs und arabische Milizen
plündern und terrorisieren die
Bevölkerung
in kleinen medizinischen Zentrum von
algenina Arbeiten keine Ärzte mehr und
können verletzte nicht operiert werden
sie mussten mit ansehen wie die Milizen
Zivilisten
wir sind so erschöpft die Lage ist
schrecklich wir haben keine
Krankenhäuser keine Medizin so wie
normale Menschen ich wünschte
internationale Organisationen könnten
kommen den Kleinkindern und alten helfen
sogar alte Frauen wurden hier geschlagen
[Musik]
in der Hauptstadt cartoum berichten
Einwohner von gelegentlichen Kampfpausen
aber die Waffenruhe wird nicht
vollständig eingehalten trotz aller
internationalen Vermittlungsversuche
Armeechef al Burhan und sein Rivale
hemeti haben zwar Gesandte ernannt für
Verhandlungen aber beide Kriegsherren
bleiben unnachgiebig
tausende fliehen die Vereinten Nationen
rechnen mit 800.000 Flüchtlingen sie
warnen im Sudan entwickle sich die
humanitäre Krise zur Katastrophe
nach Kenia dort schockiert eine Tragödie
Anhänger einer christlichen Sekte haben
sich mutmaßlich zu Tode gehungert um
Jesus zu begegnen
er hatte dazu aufgerufen der selbst
ernannte Sektenführer Paul McKenzie
heute musste er vor Gericht erscheinen
inzwischen wurden nach Behördenangaben
mindestens 110 Leichen geborgen aus
einem Massengrab in einem waldnahe der
Küstenstadt Malindi mehr von Susanne von
Lojewski
jeden Tag finden Sie neue Leichen
mindestens 110 tote Menschen haben die
Ermittler der Polizei in Malindi
inzwischen exhumiert viele darunter
Kinder das jüngste nicht einmal ein Jahr
alt zu Tode gehungert weil sie auf ihn
hörten den selbst der nannten Pastor
Paul McKenzie in seiner christlichen
Sekte predigte er seinen Anhänger das
Fasten damit sie Jesus begegnen nun sind
sie tot und hinterlassen Familien die
das grauenvolle Geschehen nicht fassen
können Steven versuchte vergeblich Frau
und Kinder vor der Sekte zu retten
Sektenmitglieder haben mir die Namen
meiner Kinder genannt die kannten mich
noch nicht mal meine Kinder haben sich
zu Tode hungert
über 4.000 Glaubensgemeinschaften sind
in Kenia registriert jeder kann eine
gründen und vom Untergang der Welt bis
zum unbedingten Gehorsam alles predigen
Kenias Präsident Hugo verglich radikale
selbst ernannte geistliche mit
Terroristen
Terroristen benutzen Religion um ihre
schrecklichen Taten umzusetzen Menschen
wie her McKenzie benutzen Religion für
genau das gleiche
auch der Fernsehprediger isekiel odero
wurde verhaftet er soll mit der Sekte
verbündet gewesen sein trotzdem
mindestens 110 Toten beteuern deren
Überleben der Anhänger noch immer aus
freien Stücken gehandelt zu haben
jeder kann seine Kirche frei wählen ob
Kirche oder eine andere niemand hat mir
etwas dafür versprochen
auch die selbst ernannten Prediger
werden so vor Gericht argumentieren für
die vielen Angehörigen im Gerichtssaal
eine Verhöhnung der Opfer
zurück nach Deutschland so viel Geld wie
noch nie fünf Milliarden Euro will der
Chip Hersteller Infineon in den Bau
einer weiteren Fabrik investieren großer
Bahnhof am Nachmittag beim symbolischen
Spatenstich in Dresden ab 2026 sollen in
der neuen Fabrik die begehrten
Halbleiter gefertigt werden damit will
sich Europa von Asien unabhängiger
machen Infineon will hier tausend neue
Arbeitsplätze schaffen
es sei der friedlichste erste Mai seit
langem gewesen sagt die Berliner Polizei
die traditionellen Demonstrationen
verliefen ruhig berlins Regierender
Bürgermeister Wegener sprach von einer
taktischen Meisterleistung der Polizei
nur vereinzelt kam es zu
Auseinandersetzung zwischen
linksradikalen Gruppen und Beamten und
7100 Polizisten waren im Einsatz 9
wurden verletzt von insgesamt 28.000
Demonstranten wurden 67 festgenommen so
die Polizei
und jetzt zur Party bei den
Wolfsburgerinnen Norbert sie stehen im
Finale der Champions League ja und
treffen dort auf Barcelona ja das war
ein echter halbfinal-krimi gestern Abend
in London zwischen dem VfL und Arsenal
vor englischer Rekordkulisse über 60.000
im Stadion am Ende siegen gewürfingen
3:2 durch einen Last Minute Tor in der
Verlängerung
kurz vor dem drohenden Elfmeterschießen
spielt die eingewechselte Jule Brand den
Ball Punkt genau zur ebenfalls
eingewechselten Pauline Bremer der
Siegtreffer zum Einzug ins Finale
Wolfsburg Trainer Tommy strot hatte
zuvor bereits eine Führung beklatscht
nachdem Alexandra Popp einen frühen
Rückstand gedreht hatte 2:1 Wolfsburg
doch Arsenal bleibt dran und gleich
durch biti zum zwei zu zwei aus 60.000
in Ekstase aber dann trifft ja noch
Pauline Bremer
ja und mal sehen wer heute Abend trifft
beim ersten DFB-Pokal Halbfinalspiel
Freiburg gegen Leipzig Sven Voss in
Freiburg was erwartet uns da gleich ja
wir erwarten natürlich das berühmte
Duell auf Augenhöhe hier Freiburg gegen
Leipzig zwei Teams die zum Besten
gehören was die Bundesliga zu bieten hat
zwei Teams die im vergangenen
Pokalfinale gestanden haben mit dem
besseren Ausgang für Leipzig und zwei
Teams die im Viertelfinale die Bayern
bzw Borussia Dortmund aus dem Wettbewerb
geworfen haben und wir erinnern uns
natürlich noch an den Jubel des SC
Freiburg Lukas Höller in der 95 Minute
der 2:1 Siegtreffer mal sehen wer heute
jubelt es geht für die beiden
Mannschaften um den Einzug ins Finale es
geht um den Einzug nach Berlin wenn man
so will also 8:15 Uhr geht's los mit dem
Halbfinale Freiburg gegen Leipzig
bis gleich sind
zum ATP-Turnier in Madrid da hat Daniel
Altmaier durch den Sieg gegen den
Spanier Schaum memonat das Viertelfinale
erreicht Alexanders wärev dagegen ist
raus aus Blick war schon früh jede
Zuversicht gewichen sein im Gegensatz zu
ihm vor Selbstvertrauen strotzen der
Gegner alkaras musste kaum mehr tun als
ihm die Bälle zurückzuspielen und in den
nächsten Fehler machen zu lassen nur
ganz selten erinnerte Zverev an den
großartigen Spieler der er vor seiner
schweren Fußverletzung war aber selbst
dann fand der Weltranglisten zweite
Carlos anpassendes Gegenmittel
statt es erhofften Tennis Krimis ein
nach bereits 82 Minuten sang und
klanglos beendetes Achtelfinale 6162
ja und damit gehört auch nicht mehr zu
den Top 20 der Weltrangliste danke schön
die Weltrangliste des schobes zeigte
sich gestern in New York mächtig
aufgebrezelt für die Spendengala des
magical musics diesmal zur Ausstellung
zu Eröffnung von Karl Lagerfeld viele
Gäste trugen die Lieblingsfarben das
2019 Verstorbenen Modedesigners Schwarz
und Weiß oder auch ein bisschen Farbe
wie Jennifer Lopez der flauschigste war
zweifellos Schauspieler Jared Leto er
holt Dichte in ganzkörper fällt Kostüm
Lagerfelds Katze schuppent
sonnige Aussichten kommen gleich von
Katja horneffer wie warm es dabei wird
es allerdings höchst unterschiedlich das
heute journal mit Marietta Slomka gegen
21 Uhr in der Halbzeitpause Ihnen einen
schönen Abend noch und bis morgen wenn
Sie mögen tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend die Gewittersaison hat
begonnen die eine oder der andere von
ihnen hat das gemerkt heute zum Beispiel
hier in Bayern aber auch in Teilen von
Baden-Württemberg oder in Sachsen-Anhalt
von der Nordsee zogen einige
Regenschauer herein sonst aber gab es
zum Teil auch strahlenden Sonnenschein
und dann ist es heute Nacht häufig klar
und dann wird es auch sehr kalt dann
sinken die Temperaturen auf plus 3 bis
-1° zwischen der oder und der Mosel da
droht also verbreitet Bodenfrost
empfindliche Pflanzen sollten sie
schützen milder bleibt die Nacht an den
Küsten von Nord und Ostsee und auch in
Süddeutschland bei sieben bis drei Grad
meistens ist der Himmel klar und in den
Wind schwachen Tälern Süddeutschlands
bildet sich auch mal Nebel oder Dunst
vielleicht gibt's noch letzte
Regenschauer am Alpen Rand einige
Wolkenfelder ziehen auch über den Norden
und Nordosten Deutschlands bei
Nordwestwind und das wird auch morgen
der Fall sein sonst aber strahlt die
Sonne höchstens in Niederbayern rechts
vielleicht noch mal für einen kleinen
Regen vor die Temperaturen sind ganz
unterschiedlich sie bleiben niedrig hier
in den Küsten von Nord- und Ostsee mit
nur so 12 13 Grad 22 Grad wenn es
dagegen am Oberrhein am Donnerstag
könnte es dort vielleicht sogar für
einen Sommertag mit 25 Grad reichen am
Freitag kommen von Westen dann schon die
nächsten Gewitter heran guten Abend